a Colorado Widow is battling her late
husband's insurance company because it
decided to cut his worker compensation
over marijuana Adam Lee died in December
while working at a Colorado ski mountain
the insurance company reduced his worker
compensation when it learned he had pot
in his system at the time of his death
Colorado is one of nine states in the
District of Columbia that allows
recreational marijuana use but as parrot
Barry Peterson shows us the insurance
company says the law is on its side I
wanted to make sure I got to work safely
Erika Lee says the last call she had
with her husband Adam was just like any
other two minutes later like I felt
something rip out of my stomach and I
couldn't understand why I couldn't even
stand up that was the moment you think
that he died yeah and you felt it I did
yes the 40-year old father of three got
caught underneath the conveyor belt at
the Colorado ski resort where he worked
as a lyft mechanic and died from chest
injuries wait go to work one day and he
goes to work one day no a sudden you
know he doesn't come home in Maine Erica
learned she'd received $800 a month for
Adams workman's compensation about half
of what she expected pinnacle assurance
the worker's comp insurance company
reduced the payments because Adam had
marijuana in his system when he died how
far does that go when you're raising
three kids
I think $800 would be close to covering
maybe gas and food maybe not even that
even though marijuana is legal in
Colorado it's still a controlled
substance that insurance companies can
take into consideration under Colorado
statute the statute was in effect long
before Colorado legalized marijuana for
recreational use and this notice is
placed at construction zones and
workplaces across the state it says
clearly if the injury results from your
use of alcohol or controlled substances
your workers compensation disability
benefits may be reduced by one-half a
medical expert who reviewed Adams
coroner's report told CBS News Adams
marijuana levels suggest he was a
chronic user but do not indicate when he
used marijuana last
Kerin Steinhauser is a criminal defense
attorney who is not directly linked to
this case
she says unlike alcohol testing for
marijuana is a unique challenge
marijuana is difficult in and of itself
because it is a controlled substance
that unlike some others can stay in the
system for up 45 to 90 days at a time so
really and truly you just don't know
from an autopsy when a person had used
the marijuana you have no idea in a
statement pinnacle assurance told CBS
News we understand the disappointment
when survivors aren't granted full
benefits the company went on to cite
Colorado's statue about cutting benefits
when alcohol or controlled substances
are found in the bloodstream to the best
of your knowledge did he ever use
marijuana while he was on the job next
month Erica will bring her case against
pinnacle to an administrative judge
hoping they will up her payment another
$800 a month they're choosing to put me
through this day after day they're
fighting me over $800 a month which to
them there's nothing but to me raising
three kids on a teacher's salary it's
everything for CBS this morning Barry
Petersen Denver